[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine football c'est officiel
leader pendant une grande partie de la
saison le fc versailles 78 et désormis
champion de nationale 2 après sa
victoire face à plabennec ce week-end
tous les détails dans cette émission
football toujours le derby sulfureux
auto montigny le bretonneux et
guyancourt s'est terminée par un triste
0 à 0 un résultat qui n'arrange aucune
des deux équipes dans ce championnat de
d2 de district reportage à suivre enfin
notre module découverte il sera
consacrée aujourd'hui au club de
taekwondo de trappes saint quentin en
yvelines structure qui fabrique les
champions français de demain l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tv 78
ces faits déjà assurés de la montée à
fin avril le fc versailles est enfin
sacré champion de nationale 2 les
joueurs de la cité rose elles se sont
imposés à domicile 1 0 face aux bretons
de plabennec que le résumé de cette
journée historique pour le club des
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Applaudissements]
des sourires sur les visages des joueurs
versailles et après une saison intense
versailles est officiellement champion
de nationale 2 après sa victoire contre
plabennec à domicile pourtant rien n'a
été simple ce samedi 14 mai en première
période les joueurs de la cité royale
déjà assurés de la montée depuis fin
avril des jouets n'arrive pas à trouver
la faille 0 0 à la pause on était un
petit manque de rythme l'équipe de
plabennec qui joue sa survie qu'ils nous
craignaient un petit peu de venir jouer
chez le champion c'est pas simple pour
eux il dit nous on avait déjà acquis
cette montée on a une petite semaine de
repos peut-être qu'on n'a pas mis le
rite qu'on mettait habituellement en
seconde période vers s'est accélèrée
marque dès les premières minutes avec ce
joli but signé cas possibles et versé
ils sont virtuellement champion malgré
quelques frayeurs sur coups de pied
arrêtés et demi finaliste de la coupe de
france résisteront aux assauts des
bretons et valideront ce premier titre
de n2 de l'histoire du club avec ce
score de 1 0
on est heureux bien sûr bien sûr qu'on
est heureux parce qu'on sait qu'on a on
a beaucoup travaillé pour résultat on
s'est beaucoup investi depuis le 1er
juillet c'est une fierté parce que c'est
quelque chose qui restera c'est un titre
donc ce qui signifie qu'on a été la
meilleure équipe de ce championnat sur
cette saison donc c'est une fierté
supplémentaire on avait un coeur de
finir comme ça là aujourd'hui sur une
victoire devant notre public de finir
cette saison sur sur cette victoire et
cette montée et ce titre de champion
cette demi-finale franchement il ya trop
de choses qui passent par la tête c'est
magnifique devant le public de faire ça
on est en extrêmement contents de leur
côté les supporters eux ce projet déjà
sur l'année prochaine et du championnat
de national or ce dès l'année prochaine
un cidre avec le niveau est beaucoup
plus élevé j'espère qu'ils vont soeur au
moins se maintenir déjà et puis on verra
pour les années suivantes mais avant de
penser à la saison prochaine vers c'est
encore deux matches à disputer leur
fermeront cette saison 2021 2022 réussi
le 28 mai prochain à domicile devant
leurs supporters au stade mon bon
on va continuer à parler des résultats
sportifs du week-end dans les yvelines
autre journaliste bixente merrien
santisteva nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
pour nous détailler tous ces résultats
sportifs on commence par du football
bixente en effet michael et c'est
bientôt la fin du championnat de
première division et à la différence de
versailles le suspense reste entier pour
savoir quel club yvelinois rejoindra la
régionale 3 l'année prochaine à deux
journées du terme le s sartrouville
occupe la tête du classement après une
victoire par forfait contre carrière
grésillons une victoire qui permet donc
de prendre deux bouts en avance sur le
voisin football club tenu en échec à la
maison contre epode un partout mais
attention les vicitmes en août un match
de retard à jouer face au chesnay pour
tenter de récupérer la première place
toutes les conditions sont réunies pour
une dernière journée épique entre le
match entre de la montée entre voisins
et sartrouville ce sera le 6 juin
prochain un petit point sur le bas du
classement au cir michel qu'est ce que
c'est mathématiquement fait depuis
plusieurs journées le fc aubergenville
descendra en d2 l'année prochaine et
sera accompagné de carrière grésillons
qui a sûrement entériner son avant
dernière place avec le forfait de ce
week-end dixième et dernier relégable
gargenville qui a deux journées pour
espérer un miracle est dépassée bois
d'arcy quatre points devant alors
souhaite alors du ve volley-ball
maintenant avec le dernier match joué
pour le club de conflent en effet un
dernier match et une défaite pour le
club de volley ball de conflans andrésy
jouy en playoffs élite masculine défaite
3 0 face aux loisirs intersport simple
le club de la ville de calais les
yvelinois terminé playoffs en 6e soit la
dernière place avec trois victoires au
compteur pour cette défaite un bilan qui
n'entache en rien la saison des conf
l'année qui s'était qualifié en
terminant 3e de leur poule d'élite bravo
à eux un mot de course à pied bixente
avec le tour de houille qui se courait
ce week end mais en effet deux courses
de 5 et 10 km pour à peu près toutes les
catégories victorieux du 5km antoine
rondo en 15 minutes 9 secondes pour le
10 km c'est jean mathis michaud qui l'a
emporté en trente et une minutes et 37
secondes côté féminines des bons temps
également aux 10 km avec irina oil en
moins de 35 minutes et au 5 km julie
bensalah qu'anne-sophie louve se sont
battus à l'arrivée pour la première
place environ 17 minutes et 30 secondes
on attendait tous ce combat de boxe
étaient seuls 10 à paris les viennois à
tony hawk a affronté le congolais martin
abako les pour son 12e combats chez les
professionnels oui une défaite la
première pour tony yoka dépassé dès le
premier round par son adversaire martin
bacot les malgré un genou posé au sol
dès l'entrée en matière sur un un coup
de main de son adversaire et des routes
particulièrement difficile je pense au
3e au 5e rang notamment il parviendra
quand même à terminer le combat au
courage debout pour s'incliner
finalement au point martin était plus
fort tout le monde a pu le voir
félicitations à lui il est temps de
retourner travailler at il déclaré dès
la fin du combat au micro du speaker une
défaite pour le faire mûrir pour le
boxeur dont la carrière devrait être
encore monde je suppose que vous en
débattre et très vite avec vos experts
michael we rendez-vous dans le prochain
siro par les sports on va parler voile
maintenant widows yvelinois qu'avait
pris le départ de la bermudes reis bien
sûr louis burton qui a terminé la boucle
du golfe de gascogne ce samedi après
presque six jours de chevauchée
solitaire un résultat de bon augure donc
pour l'illinois qui s'est ainsi
qualifiée par la même occasion pour la
route du rhum qui partira le 6 novembre
prochain en compagnie bien sûr de son
monocoque bureau vallée l'autre
yvelinois série b lyon a rêvé lui en six
jours et deux heures à la septième
position une bonne performance pour
l'ancien participants au vendée globe
dont c'était la première course de
petits formats en solitaire il a déclaré
avoir passé un très bon moment malgré
bien sûr quelques petites galères je
cite et on continuera à les suivre
évidemment sur les prochaines courses
de voile alors du rugby pour terminer
sur une très mauvaise opération pour nos
clubs divine engagés dans les phases
fine de fédérale 3 ce dimanche où jouer
le match aller le mlsgp a perdu 15 à 9 à
domicile contre gijon et de son côté
versailles a perdu à l'extérieur 26-10
contre servian boujan les deux équipes
yvelinoise sont donc en difficulté dans
ces 16e de finale verdict final dimanche
prochain avec les matches retour ça
s'annonce bouillant à bixente merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions vous
retrouve bientôt sur ce plateau on
continue cette page résultats par du
football dans le championnat de 2e
division de district mauvaise opération
pour montier aux bretons eux dans la
course à la montée l'easy ni mon temps
concédé le match nul à domicile dans le
derby face à à guyancourt des images de
nicolas briche
un derby pour croire la montée en fin de
saison ce dimanche 15 mai montigny le
bretonneux recevait but en cours sur son
terrain à l'occasion de la 20e journée
de d2 de district appliquée lésigny
montant se procure des occasions sur
cette première période sans faire sauter
le verrou guillon courtois le score à la
pause 0 à 0 encore moins difficilement
la rencontre mais après le premier quart
d'heure on s'est bien repris
j'ai une très grosse opportunité je
pense que si si on marque le match il
est pas pareil donc un peu frustrant
mais c'est ça le football première
période où on s'observe un petit peu il
ya une équipe qui est très en place
compte une équipe très difficile à jouer
avec un gros bloc avec un gros bloc
beaucoup genre milles du terrain en
seconde période la dynamique s'inverse
guyancourt pouces mais n'arrive pas à
marquer face aux verts le score
n'évoluera pas score final 0 à 0 à chaud
comme ça j'irai beaucoup de frustration
parce que j'estime qu'on aurait dû faire
beaucoup mieux en aurais je pense qu'on
a dominé un smash on a pas mal de
situations et on a raté beaucoup de
dernier geste dernière passe mauvais
contrôle pense que dans l'ensemble on a
dominé ce match on a manqué d'efficacité
offensive on va te faire christ roi
parce qu'on a deux équipes qui se valent
et nous on avait à coeur de pas de
gagner ce match parce que c'est un derby
ce match nul n'arrange aucune des deux
équipes du en cours est sous pression
pour conserver sa troisième place au
classement sur son côté monti le
bretonneux pourrait ne pas monter en fin
de saison lésigny montrent un jour en un
match crucial à domicile face à houilles
le nouveau leader le 29 mai prochain
on va maintenant parler à box le 28 mai
prochain un gala de boxe anglaise sera
organisé au complexe sportif europe à
elancourt par la team farrugia au total
une quinzaine de combats amateurs sont
programmées pendant la soirée on écoute
l'entraîneur du club tanguy jane nous
présente cet événement c'est notre
interview express
[Applaudissements]
c'est un grand gala mais c'est un bon
gars là niveau national voilà il ya des
gens qui viennent de bretagne du nord de
la france enfin un peu partout de la
france dans la france pour rencontrer
les boxeurs on va dire du 78 et à dix
boxeurs du club de chez nous plus des
boxeurs que ça sonne marly-le-roi les
mureaux enfin un peu partout du son de
la verrière un peu partout du 78 qui
viendront aussi affronter les boxeurs de
2 d'ailleurs quoi voilà de la france
[Musique]
ça permet aux boxeurs de progresser de
se faire un nom aussi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de ces démos il ya beaucoup de
nouveaux qui vont commencer et certains
qui vont sûrement passer pro d'ici un an
un an voire deux ans ils vont commencer
à faire leurs armes comme ibrahim fofana
liesse et ja oui
voilà il y en a un petit jeune là qui
arrive de montigny-le-bretonneux qui
sait mathias voilà vautrin qui vient de
commencer il a déjà huit combats six
victoires et je pense que c'est sur mon
avenir
[Musique]
c'est grave ça nous manque bien sûr là
on est un peu dans l'inconnu comme je
lis il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont sur
leur premier combat du club mais
oui oui c'est ça fait plaisir c'est
vraiment ça fait plaisir on va retrouver
les lettres de noblesse d'ici voilà le
prochain gala on retrouvera les vrais
ils vraiment que je recommande à chez
nous
dans notre module découverte aujourd'hui
coup de projecteur sur l'école taekwondo
de trappes 50 ans ni vis ni structure
qui fabrique les champions de demain je
vous propose de découvrir ce club des
images de justin brasil
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur
l'école de taekwondo de trappes 50 ans
ni vis ni structure qui conclut de 300
licenciés qui fait partie des meilleures
structures de france
[Musique]
pour nous présenter ce club je suis aux
côtés de djawad le coach alors jawad
quelle est l'histoire de ce club bonsoir
bas laissant ce club le tt a été créé en
suite à nos départs du bct où il y avait
plusieurs sections
et bat depuis 2015 on n'a pas notre
indépendance et voilà ça fait sept ans
qu'on existe et après sept ans
d'existence au premier bilan ça se passe
bien j'ai l'impression qu'à écouter ça
se passe très bien en 2019 on a été
meilleurs clubs de france cadets juniors
à notre surprise
ensuite moi il ya une qu'ovide et/ou à
la reprise va ça a repris cette année et
on va encore cette année on est les
meilleurs clubs de france cadets juniors
pour la deuxième fois consécutive et
comment vous l'expliquez bas je pense
que c'est beaucoup de travail beaucoup
d'investissements du stade va être
l'équipe du bureau alors on s'investit
beaucoup les jeunes et s'épanouissent et
je pense que leur trouver la bonne
recette pour pouvoir réussir parce que
cette année on compte 14 titres là selon
ce qui est parent pour une ville de
vendée fier on espère que ça va
continuer comme ça et comment
l'expliquer que ça se passe aussi bien
ici le taekwondo a attrapée est-ce que
vous avez une idée
ba s'est séparé de plusieurs années
c'est on est une très bonne structure
on va dire des bénévoles comme géniteur
qui s'investissent énormément
limite on voit plus nausées nos élèves
que nos propres enfants et
je pense que c'est ça c'est un succès si
on fait ça avec notre coeur la passion
on a envie qu'ils réussissent
et puis on met des choses en place ils
ont quasiment cours tous les jours ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est
c'est la plupart c'est des athlètes de
haut niveau
donc voilà on est fiers d'eux j'espère
que ça va continuer comme ça le club
dans sa nouvelle structure on peut le
dire est une fabrique à champions
grossman entraînement s'entraîne quasi
tous les jours c'est vraiment des
athlètes de haut niveau la plupart sont
champions de france il ya un suivi
derrière
et ouais voilà donc je pense c'est ça la
clé de la réussite
c'est vraiment l'investissement au
travail et il lâche pas la faire
modifier je le disais ce club compte
environ 300 licenciés 300 350 licenciés
est ce qu'on peut dire que trap est une
terre de taekwondo
je pense je pense que le temps des
chronos parce qu'on ait recours n'a
reconnu au niveau national et
international on a des résultats partout
dans le monde on représente comme il se
doit les couleurs de la ville et de la
ville nouvelle comme vous le savez le
depuis un mois on a changé de
dénomination maintenant ça peut être tu
étais sky et koita comme de trappes et
saint quentin en yvelines donc au delà
de la vie de maintenant on représente
toute l'agglomération
et ça je pense qu'on est fiers et puis
j'espère que ça va continuer comme ça on
parle et vous avez formé de nombreux
champions vous jawad personnellement
vous êtes là depuis quelques années
est-ce que c'est aussi un peu votre
réussite quand même ce club je sais que
vous êtes assez modeste mais mais c'est
quand même votre réussite oui oui bah
y'a pas que moi il ya on a une grosse
équipe derrière il ya du ray le
président qui est aussi entraîneur
j'aime et j'ai d'autres entraîneurs
aussi
il ya john ya patrick jeu donc c'est
vraiment un travail d'équipé je pense
après oui on est fiers parce que au
moins 11 i ce qu'on fait ça sert à
quelque chose que après moi je fais un
peu figure de grand frère donc il me
respecte beaucoup après voilà je suis
beaucoup derrière eux moi enfin jusqu'au
bout comme ça je les lâche pas et
voilà je pense comme ça moi je comme un
grand frère et je veux qu'il réussisse
quoi on a un prix on a l'impression que
chaque détail compte dans le geste du
tijd de taekwondo on l'a vu tout à
l'heure vous avez un peu corrigé vous
avez dit taper plus tôt à cet endroit là
plutôt qu'un autre à prendre son élan à
tel endroit est ce que c'est le souci du
détail peut être qui fait la différence
ah ben c'est ça c'est exactement ça
surtout à haut niveau c'est les petits
détails qui font gagner donc on est
obligé d'être derrière eux de vraiment
les rectifier pour qu'ils aient la bonne
gestuelle et c'est vraiment c'est ça
joue sur des détails
le haut niveau oui
et en compétition à ça fonctionne vous
l'avais dit à plusieurs titres nationaux
des titres aussi haut niveau au niveau
européen est ce qu'il ya des champions
qui peuvent aller encore plus loin on
pense aux jo de 2024 aux jo-2000 28 cas
on l'espère oui en tout cas nous nous on
s'entraîne pour ça le léger au c'est la
consécration pour tout athlète de haut
niveau c'est le rêve à atteindre et oui
bah on espère pour 2024 après moi j'ai
beaucoup de très jeunes mères
2028 je pense qu'on aura les 2024 on
croise les doigts est-ce que vous avez
des noms peut-être lui donner
bages et khalid adapté en cas l'insset
ginastera wilks a été récemment
championne de france gm en chef qui va
faire les gens lisent ya dans la semaine
prochaine est l'équivalent des jeux
olympiques pour les lycéens il y aura
pas y aura tout le monde entier et moi
j'ai plusieurs ag djibril j'en ai
énormément toqué vous avez trop trop
beaucoup autour c'est que ces bosses
examen dernière question quel est votre
plus grand rêve pour ce club de trappes
bas mon plus grand rêve c'est
cesser d'avoir quelques athlètes en tout
cas pour la haute performance et d'avoir
des athlètes aux jeux olympiques déjà ça
serait bien 2024 ou 2028 vous prenez oui
voilà moi je prends les deux
salles l'avenir nous le dira merci
beaucoup jawad est justement ces pépites
on va les voir dans quelques instants
[Musique]
je suis donc maintenant avec deux
pépites du club moncef et antoine alors
moncef qu'est ce qui t'a donné envie
d'être ici dans ce club de taekwondo à
trappes j'ai commencé déjà d'économe
parce que c'était à mon père qu'il
faisait juste et pando m a donc inscrit
et depuis j'ai mes fans du club j'étais
content ou attrape depuis je continue
c'est mon passe temps mon loisir et
j'adore ce sport
ça fait 11 ans et sat et attrapes ouais
ça fait marron zeman et sa femme ont
émané je suis social trappe
tu as commencé à 5-6 ans et ça et
pourquoi et pourquoi trappe spécialement
trappe parce que déjà mon père
connaissait déjà j'ajoute à l'ancienne
il s'entraîne avec lui et comme il a su
qui il avait un club à trappes et que
j'habite à attrape aussi c'est la
possibilité d'y aller directement et
maintenant à voir où j'en suis
alors toit en toile ça fait cinq ans à
peu près quand tu fais du taekwondo oui
cinq ans explique nous pourquoi
déjà c'est parce que mon père est
séduite et points d'eau avant et je suis
allé à sa démonstration et ça me
plaisait bien du combat inscrit qu'est
ce qui te plaît qu'est ce que tu aimes
faire dans ce sport bah c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup d'ambiance et puis
c'est beaucoup de compétition
et pourquoi tu as choisi claude eutrope
pas parce que c'est un des meilleurs
clubs et du coup voilà alors toi mon sac
du coup tu es champion vice champion
d'europe champion de france également
tout ça à 16 ans
alors pourquoi pourquoi cette
progression si fulgurante puisque j'ai
eu j'ai envie de m'entraîner j'ai eu
envie de donner le meilleur de moi-même
montrer aux gens que je pouvais faire
mieux
je me suis entraîné fort à la salle j'ai
montré mes performances en compétition
et du coup tout ce que tout les tous les
résultats que je fais me plaît et du
coup j'essaye de continuer à faire
sérieux à faire ces résultats la suite
on continua à pour former dans un sport
encore et encore est-ce que tu
t'attendais ou pas avoir des résultats
aussi important rapidement non je ne
m'attendais pas
afin de performance aussi vite partage
pensionnat ils ont fait mieux que moi
mais bon
ça reste le fruit d'un entraînement
antoine alors toi tu es déjà vice
champion d'europe et champion de france
aussi à à 10 ans explique nous bah je me
suis entraîné beaucoup beaucoup
j'ai dû rater presque aucun cours et du
coup bah voilà est-ce que tu t'attendais
toi aussi à faire ces résultats aussi
rapidement non pas du tout non et est ce
que tu es le premier surpris du coup
comment ça s'est passé des compétitions
raconte-nous basse et jawad au départ
que nous inscrire c'était pour tester au
depor et au fil du temps je me suis
moi j'ai vu que j'avais une progression
du coup j'ai continué voilà ce qui jawad
en fait finalement combat c'est le très
propre et caen et vous corrige en on
voit qu'il est très très a séduit
regarde chaque nouvelle vous faites oui
ils nous regardent beaucoup et puis
c'est comme ça qu'on prouvera qu'on
progresse c'est comme ça qu'on progresse
avec djawad c'est la rigueur avant tout
la rigueur bien sûr il est dur avec nous
mais est-ce pour notre bien et nous on
le sait c'est un mutant c'est grâce à ça
qu'on progresse il est derrière nous à
chaque fois pour chaque petit détail il
nous fait corriger et à chaque fois
c'est ce qu'on nous sert compétition
donc là matin on ramasse énormément
parce que c'est grâce à lui qu'on fait
ces résultats et grâce aussi aux halles
un autre autre entraîneur aussi yann le
burel représentants du club oui il a dit
tout à l'heure dans l'interview chaque
détail compte en compétition tu
confirmes je confirme c'est un petit
détail pour ne fait pas en compétition
peut nous coûter la victoire c'est très
important
est ce qu'on peut dire vous entraîner
dur ici à la trappe on le voit derrière
toulon et transpirant tournée evidian
les presque en fin de séance on a
l'impression que les entraînements sont
assez compliquées quand même ici ouais
c'est vrai désert en intensité on
s'entraîne avec les grands comme on l'a
vu jean sassus énormément sa s'entraîne
fort parce que tout le monde veut
prouver quelque chose en national et en
international le monde est meilleur que
tout le monde dans ce club même entre
nous du coup on se donne les moyens les
capacités est ce qui fait que la matin
ça transpire et qu'on donne les
résultats
l'international nous reste encore
l'énergie ou pas la fin la session
d'entraînement
non non c'est vrai que non mais même
quand on n'a plus d'énergie c'est là où
il faut continuer à travailler pour elle
et le plus au plus profond de notre
mental ce qui va nous servir aussi sur
le tatami qu'en combat on va maintenant
parler des objectifs de vos objectifs
c'est quoi tes objectifs à toi mons et
déjà déjà
le qualifier l'équipe de france pour les
championnats du monde en août et
faire une médaille j'espère au gymnase
own de jeux olympiques scolaire la
semaine prochaine et aussi une médaille
ce week-end comme celui-ci est pourtant
antoine les championnats d'europe et
terol le plus de compétitions possibles
et revenir au maximum de médailles si
j'ai bien compris au nord et les jeux
olympiques pour vous ça on bientôt ça
sera en 2024 ici à à paris est ce que
c'est un objectif notamment pour toi mon
cher à antoine toi je crois que tu
encore un petit peu de jeunes ont quand
même mais pourtant moncef pour moi
peut-être pas 2028 sûrement mais
en tout cas même si je ne peux pas faire
les jo de 2024 je vais prouver au
maximum de mes capacités aux entraîneurs
l'entraîneur que je suis le j'aimerais
être le prochain favoris aux jo-2000 28
donc c'est pour ça que je vais essayer
de je vais m'entraîner continuer à
performer et essayer de rattraper les
meilleurs 2024 un peu juste peut-être à
16 ans tu auras du coup 18 ans en 2024
c'est peut-être un peu juste ouais un
peu juste parce que j'ai à votre
adversaire en france qui sont cons sont
plus grands que moi quand plus
d'expérience et contre qui je ne voulais
pas encore le niveau malheureusement mai
à 1028 j'espère nous reste encore six
ans c'est tout à fait faisable et on les
visaient maximum de la question qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter à tous les
deux antoine qu'est ce qu'on peut
souhaiter le plus de réussite possible
et puis à
des victoires voilà le concept bas comme
la jane plus de réussite pour tous les
gens du club surtout aussi pour le club
pour qu'ils peuvent pas manquer cucina
pro forma à l'international et voilà ce
serait là un bonheur pour nous merci à
tous les deux je vous laisse retourner à
l'entraînement merci
[Musique]
vous l'aurez compris l'école de
taekwondo de trappes 50 ans neeve il
fait partie des meilleures structures de
france et peut-être que certains
athlètes présents ici dans cette salle
participant aux jeux olympiques de 2024
ou 2028
et on termine par un événement caritatif
le tiebreak roland garros fondée par
l'ivi noise véronique chaplin est
organisée ce lundi au golf robert un
sens la frontière du 78 le concept est
toujours le même des initiations sont
organisées sur un golf avec des enfants
du département en parallèle des sportifs
de haut niveau jouer au golf et enfin
des enchères prestigieux sont ouvertes
au public cette année c'était la 30e
édition c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv
[Musique]